l'académie des neuf avec catherine rich
arlette thomas michel lève il fait son
entrée dans l'académie claude lemesle à
ses côtés alice dona ou qu'elle est
belle daniel pecqueur et laurence art
les académies de 10 donc père est radié
et gadgets sweet valentine
avec vous du seuil ne forge pas une mais
petite question en petite série
voici le premier thème les dix plus
grands lacs du monde alors les siennes
avec qui vous voulez vous jouer regarder
des codes qui sont là avec daniel
prévost
olala serait un grand spécialiste en
laque 20 de ses enfants souffre quatre
des plus grands lacs du monde daniel
alors en chine
comment s'est fait souffler plus fort tu
es là qui relie le la attendait oui lac
daumesnil nom du bois de boulogne le lac
le lac aux pics atteints
vous écoutez attendez laissez moi
réfléchir l'ontario ontario le lac
ontario oui bravo commandant dans le lac
lochte à vos noms le gymnase à vos qui
est près du congo belge vraiment le lac
léman 10 millions le lac monia
le lac bout janot oui oui exact le lac
mono michka exact le lac mais rooney v
exact le lac pontbriand soit
extraordinaire ont terminé le lac monge
classe vohra minutes promet daniel
provost est jolie et j'ajoute si le
temps me reste un tout petit peu le trac
colombie bourg où nous est enfin à
nouveau la queue qui est actuellement en
vente des grands magasins dunnes lac
semblait way or au rayon au rayon castle
maixent ibanez ou daniel prévost nous
sommes médusés par votre culture
malheureusement certes tous les lacs
oumma et cités sont bons mais c'était
après la petite sonnerie pour mémoire je
peux tout même vous citez c'est la
mémoire de qui le lac supérieur lac
victoria michigan tanganyka de la tchad
lac huron baïkal la loure gelé bien j'ai
dire ça mais j'ai dit tout ça dans la
langue des pays
un autre thème les os de la jambe et du
pied
c'est curieux mon impression vous
hésitez tout ça interrogé thierry roland
les choses mais je les blocs et qui vous
gène 182 c'est à vous marie vous n'avez
pas enlever votre micro je pense que
vous allez le faire qu'elle voulait me
garder
donnez moi votre micro trouver le gardez
vous allez vous installer et tiré au
sort tout de suite un petit billet que
brigitte va me donner voilà qui est fait
alors le thème et vous allez commencer
avec pierre bachelet c'est le pain top
chrono une minute pierre bachelet
première question pourquoi mon chouchou
du pain pour grossir nicole croisille
que mettons sur du pain du beurre
thiery role of two le pain chez le
boulanger y oblige citez moi ne pas 25
yves lecoq lamy que peut-il y avoir ou
peut-on trouver du par les deux
questions désagréables sur la table est
ce que le pape est accompagnée seule
question dany saval m'arrive je le
préfère vous aimez le pas comment grille
et daniel prévost présent je ne mange
pas de pain
moi j'ai vu du père au petit déjeuner
croyez-moi croyez moi ça n'est pas
facile du tout de trouver 10 questions
très simples sur un sur un thème donné
merci marie vous avez gagné tout de même
162 supplémentaire donc brigitte va vous
remettre dans quelques instants
attendions bonjour bienvenue sur antenne
2 voici les deux candidats qui vont
passer cette demi heure avec nous
valérie et james valérie bonjour bonjour
je m'appelle va ériger 60 ans où je sais
je les fais pas j'en ai 18 18
j'habite à rouen et je fais des études
de mathématiques en quelle année de vous
en première année quatre et trois villes
sans réfléchir qu'après trois attendent
in 43 43 12
james e bonjour je m'appelle craignent
que j'habite en ligne et je suis
photographe photographe donc orléans
face à rouen le premier des trois rendez
vous voici les 9 15
c'est à vous valérie de commencer avec
quelques anicien voulez vous jouez vous
allez disposer d'un petit rond pour
tracer une ligne
j'aurais joué avec jean marc thibault
jean marc thibault bonjour jean marc
thibault
bonjour j'ai 18 ans oui l'angleterre
jean-marc en novembre 1940 âge oui
l'angleterre en novembre 1982 découvre
avec surprise que le maniaque sexuel
geoffrey prime qui défraie la chronique
et le manach on extrapole associe ce
maniaque qui défraie la chronique est
vraiment un très très mauvais anglais
pourquoi gens me top chrono 30 secondes
à très mauvais anglais c'est un étranger
peut-être c'est un espion étrangers 1
un espion étrangers
belgique un espion tout court
un d'accord très bonne réponse de jean
marc thibault cet employé du
contre-espionnage travailler pour les
allemands
depuis 14 ans c'est une histoire de
moeurs qui a démasqué cet anglais
amateurs de jeunes femmes même design
que foucault qui montrait son micro film
sous le manteau asim dans l'académie des
9 james et à vous de jouer
eh bien nous allons reprendre sim sim
bonjour monsieur simon bonjour messieurs
dames en 1917
oui madame poincaré femme du président
de la république est l'objet d'un
enlèvement manqué la presse sera muselé
et n'en parlera pas à cause de la
personnalité de l'agresseur qui sera
également muselés par la suite pourquoi
si les bains je vais vous dire je le
sais car ce cetc c'est mon grand père
qui a enlevé madame poincaré ah bon non
mais je vais vous dire mon grand-père
était je vais vous faire je peux vous
faire à rim
oui je veux dire ami vous allez
comprendre pourquoi mon grand père était
employé dans un zoo et il était orangs
outans oui et c'est un orang outan qui
en a qui a enlevé madame poincaré
excellente réponse de cible il
s'agissait en effet d'un orang outan
échappé d'un cirque voisin de l'elysée
il sauta sur la présidente poincaré l'a
pris par la taille et tenta de
l'emporter dans les arbres aujourd'hui
je vais trouver à la point car la
branche en branche
merci sim une croix devant singh bagri
c'est à vous je vois jouer avec bernard
menez bernard menez bonjour
en 1947 madame poinsot chapuis obtint
une distinction qu'aucune femme n'a vécu
jusqu alors en france qu'elle ait ce
poste de haute responsabilité bernard
elle a une grande responsabilité et une
grande responsabilité donc qu'elles
étaient hauts placés alors comme vous
ces politiques oui oui oui mais c'est
tout lui mais politique grand bon ben je
sais pas moi elle était à me semble
je sais pas ministre les choses comme ça
mais alors me nice alors qu'est ce qui
fit d'originalité ministre donc la femme
ministre pham machaël suis la première
femme à ben oui oui oui la première bien
sûr oui bien sûr dressés bonne réponse
bernard à la santé publique dans le
gouvernement schumann c'était en 1947
très bonne réponse de bernard menez 22
plus pour valérie et un petit rond
devant vous bernard que faites-vous
james et bien marcel maréchal
marcel maréchal que je vais aller
rejoindre dans quelques instants
marcel maréchal lyonnais exilés à
marseille vivante actuellement à paris
voilà vous savez tout lui la question le
26 mars marcel le 14 septembre et le 29
septembre 1908 eu lieu en france un
phénomène atmosphérique lumineux
pourtant considérée comme rare chez nous
quel est ce phénomène top chrono 30
secondes
nuit blanche non non marcel enfants
voilà un phénomène atmosphérique l'asu
na kwa
une éclipse des éclairs au chocolat sous
celle où la soucoupe une soucoupe
volante non un extraterrestre ou les
soufflets monsieur castelli la soucoupe
volante
non c'est pas ça du tout du tout une
connerie une aurore boréale
il y en eut 3908 certains journaux
allèrent jusqu'à prévoir la fin du monde
et d'autre et vire une une punition du
ciel en verre l'anticléricalisme
heureusement que jamais papier moi je
regrette marcel maréchal mais ne partez
pas vous allez comprendre pourquoi
valérie marcel maréchal bien sûr pour
tracer votre ligne il est un animal
marcel maréchal pour lequel il ne reste
que trois chasseurs professionnelle en
france quel est cet aliment est citée
moi plein d'animaux on va bien tomber
sur le bon top chrono
le grill non lours non lapin de garenne
non nous eh ben non je passe milliards à
que l'on l'appelle de théâtre non est
doté le blaireau non le serpent lequel à
sonnette
non ça dans la vie c'est de souffler pas
mais on siffle et enfin une ligne
félicitations avoue valérie grâce à la
réponse de marcel maréchal sein de
supplémentaire pour vous les compte 130
à deux pour dix petits à 2 james ami
photographe il va falloir vous ressaisir
notre deuxième rendez vous tout de suite
si vous êtes d'accord avec le dernier
des neuf coucou et avant de jouer au
dernier 2,9 je me dirige justement vers
marcel maréchal
alors comme ça on quitte marseille
qu'est ce qui se passe on ne s'y plaît
plus à marseille la criée vous aussi oui
mais moi je rentre tous les week-ends
c'est ça moi aussi non non on est ici
affectivement à paris avec deux
spectacles les 3 mousquetaires à créteil
une jours jusqu'au 27 février et puis au
rond point des champs elysées chez chez
jean louis barrault spectacle est
coproduit par la criée par jean louis
barrault et madeleine renaud avec marie
christine barrault et moi aussi je joue
là dedans je joue le rôle-titre dylan
une pièce de l'auteur américain sinda
michael ce alors parlons des trois
mousquetaires crée d'ailleurs au théâtre
de la criée à marseille c'est sam voilà
alors c'est important de décentraliser
la création pour ensuite venir à paris
c'est une belle paris c'est une ville de
tournai comme une autre
très bien je suis heureux de vous
entendre dire le les cascades de ces les
combats c'est justement on en parlait
avec jean marc thibault la ccl d'un
prestigieux cascadeur enfin l'ancien
comédien aussi mais qui sait très bien
réglée saxe et raul billerey qui a fait
un travail magnifique on a travaillé
pendant cinq mois avec
des cascadeurs et des comédiens françois
dunoyer qui fait d'artagnan et je crois
que c'est assez s'éteint c'est un des
gros atouts du spectacle où je n'aurais
pas pu faire ce spectacle sans raul
vraiment un grand spécialiste paris
après marseille n'est qu'une étape pour
ces trois mousquetaires bas après nous
allons retourner l'enfance et puis après
nous partons en amérique du sud mais
j'ai les questions qu'on a joué aussi ça
en chine
après ce sera le premier contact avec la
chine oui avec l'amérique du sud aussi
j'ai fait beaucoup de tournées enfin pas
avec ce spectacle mais avec d'autres
spectacles en europe
enfin dans toute l'europe et dans tous
les pays socialistes et en amérique
aussi du nord mais jamais en amérique du
sud et jamais évidemment en chine
marcel maréchal merci donc mise en scène
par vous les trois mousquetaires à
créteil nous sommes bien d'accord ça
emerson la chaîne le comédien avec marie
christine barrault dans une mise en
scène de jean pierre gorges alors au
point des champs elysées je suis pas
très doué pour le jeu là je suis désolé
pour james je suis très intimidée pas si
j'avais pas mes cartons ah oui il y en a
quand même qui sont très brillants salle
échoué mais l'erreur pour james
maintenant c'est un vrai ou faux donc
hier pas 50 solutions vous allez voir
avant sa première question 1
j'enlève le trombone voilà un eudémis
est une figure en patinage artistique
vrai ou faux marcel à ce faux c'est faux
entièrement d'accord et oui c'est un
papillon très bonne réponse de marcel
maréchal
alice dona on peut applaudir à l'iss bon
j'ai un fils dans l'académie alice un
aigle peugue l'attirent glh hier un
aigle peugue l'attirent vrai ou faux
plenty visa et ben faut aller allons-y
oui oui valérie valérie un aigle peugue
l'activé wheel bien sûr je regrette
valérie vous ne marquez pas bondi à 2
alice reste avec nous monsieur castelli
monsieur kassai l'hyper du lit est une
parabole mathématiques l'hyper du lait
oui est une parabole mathématiques
in fine il faut eh bien c'est faux bravo
philippe gas cité c'est le culte de la
sainte vierge chez les catholiques c'est
impossible maintenant oui si mme haddad
et je me relève parce que je suis un peu
écroulé en plus vous êtes vraiment des
coiffes et aujourd'hui alors pied de
mammouth que j'ai là là la gaude triche
oui et un singe et ça tombe encore sur
vous l'amérique du sud
eh ben c'est complètement faux faux
d'accord et bien c'est complètement vrai
au revoir sim
merci beaucoup racée arrête didier houi
une personne atrabilaire est une
personne ayant subi l'ablation de la
vésicule biliaire
non c'est faux c'est une personne qui a
qui y est de mauvaise humeur non pensez
vous à ce que si bien pour lui que gérer
oui excellent bien quand ces précisions
apportées par notre ami relève didier
faut séparer les une personne d'humeur
chagrine bernard menez le misanthrope
c'est l'atrabilaire amoureux je crois
oui tout à fait mais bernard menez
richard strauss et un compositeur de
nationalité allemande vrai ou faux
maintenant je comprend d'anciens
autrichien alors vrai ou faux
alors vite oui non allez faut petit faux
faux faux et yoann était autrichien le
premier le deuxième mais richard au
revoir monsieur menez catherine lara
catherine la moldavie est une république
de l'union soviétique vrai ou faux la
moldavie vrai ou faux faux faux
j'irai faut aussi et bien c'est parfait
et d'autant que c'est vrai je regrette
merci beaucoup
enfin catherine à tout à l'heure jean
marc thibault oui en 1804 napoléon et
mythes un projet de campagne en
australie vrai ou faux vrai vrai ouais
ouais bonne réponse en effet de jean
marc thibault vrai il reste en notre
compagnie c'est à michel luccioni
maintenant de jouer
michine le bénin est une province du
gabon le bénin d'une province du cap un
faux ou dit faux james gilles faut aussi
c'est faux ou bien sûr c'est l'ex
dahomey c'est un pays le bénin
merci voyons voir marcel maréchal vous
êtes toujours là le premier rallye paris
dakar s'est déroulée en 1979 vrai ou
faux marcel vrai vrai oui vrai c'est
vrai en effet bonne réponse de marcel
maréchal spécialiste quand paris dakar
et sans marseille ces normes marçais
l'italie a remporté la coupe du monde de
foot 1982 sur un score de 2 à 1 contre
l'allemagne
vrai ou faux oui mais alors 2 1 vrai ou
faux
oui allez je dirais vrai vrai j ai le
troisième but vous l'avez ou blanc
c'était 3-1 avec la demi-finale mois
merci à 10 ans
philippe castelli un bardeau qui va sans
doute répondre avant même que je ne
formulent la question les indes
orientales sont les anciennes colonies
néerlandaises formant aujourd'hui
l'indonésie oui c'est vrai vrai et bien
c'est vrai merci au public a repris avec
wii présente mandarin est un mot
d'origine portugaise mandarin oui je
veux dire je m'en fous totalement vrai
au fond je crois que c'est vrai bref je
revois aussi c'est en effet très très
bonnes réponses quand est didier dans la
stivo s'est mêlé est ce m e est le sait
mêler avec 3 accent est le dieu grec du
vin et de l'ivresse bacchus étant celui
des romains vrai ou faux
wilko est belle oui c'est vrai vous
dites vrai où il faudrait c'est faux
bien sûr merci beaucoup
c'était dionysos ah oui oui enfin on ira
boire un verre tout à l'heure va tant
pis michel missionné le béryl b er y est
lé est une variété d'émeraude
j'en ai même nom le berry est une
variété d'émeraude vous dites vrai ah
oui c'est vrai si l on a vu chez
confiance je devrais le problème c'est
que celle inverse l'émeraude qui est une
variété de béryl séparé tomber dans les
brodeurs galuchat à l'essieu
sapa
mantis païenne et un insecte au même
titre que la mante religieuse
oui ouais vous dites frais ouais c'est
en effet vraie bonne réponse de marcel
maréchal
on va pas les départager ilic a dit
louis xiv eu une sépulture nocturne car
on craignait des émeutes populaires
hostiles des faits vrais ouais c'est
vrai je dirais c'est en effet vrai
félicitations aux philippe castelli et
les plus profondes questions c'est tout
même les pauses et ensuite on servait à
des questionnaires dit de blocage pour
vous départager
c'est acquis joey starr même je crois
oui elle est à moi je suis toujours là
morphée et la déesse grecque des songes
morphée oui oui je crois ou ai fait
d'accord très bien morphée c'est le dieu
et non pas la dsd son jardin c'est une
divine y aborde ce sont les fous c'est
le dieu des c'est un monsieur morphée je
regrette alain didier et maintenant il
nous faut départager
marcel maréchal et philippe castellini
marcel maréchal la plus haute montagne
de grande bretagne situé en écosse
c'est faux c'est faux j'ai info vous dit
faux c'était vrai merci beaucoup de
scènes maréchal et nous allons a clamé
le dernier des neuf en la personne de
philippe castelli
ça va ça va merci des castings
vous jouez pour valérie un sens à deux
supplémentaires pour valérie georges
moins d'eau et le vrai nom de georges
courteline c'est un cadeau vrai ou faux
et vrai c'est vrai vrai c'est en effet
vrai félicitations à notre héros de ce
deuxième je m'interdis castelli qui
permit bon ben vous pouvez atterrir
maintenant au québec en mai à valérie de
s'enrichir de 100 à 2 supplémentaires
les scores 281,2 pour valérie brigitte
voulez vous remettre les billets 70 à
deux pour james et tout de suite le
premier rendez-vous en chansons avec
notre invité de la semaine voici alice
dona laisser passer la chanson alice
dona